fue en este momento cuando la
ultraderecha de supuestamente había
planeado atentar contra el presidente
francés en medio de la multitud en un
acto conmemorativo del armisticio en el
este de Francia en 2018 la policía
acercó al grupo y realizó detenciones
tras interrogatorios llegaron hasta el
presunto líder Jean Pierre
jubilado y dueño de un taller buyer hizo
comentarios sobre atacar a macron en
público con un cuchillo de cerámica
las autoridades encontraron armas en su
automóvil y en su casa aquí en San
George de comer al sur de
en Facebook Boyer había pedido la
eliminación de aquellos que buscaban
hacerle daño y describió el jefe de
estado como un pequeño dictador
histérico
buyer asegura que nunca tuvo intención
de actuar pese a sus palabras ahora once
hombres y dos mujeres van a juicio todos
forman parte de un grupo de Facebook
llamado los barcos o los locos En las
reuniones del grupo donde los
participantes se entrenaban en tiro y
primeros auxilios se discutían planes
para secuestrar diputados y realizar un
golpe de estado los sucesos se
produjeron mientras se extendía el
malestar social en Francia Un aumento de
los precios del combustible dio lugar a
la primera protesta de los chalecos
amarillos el 17 de noviembre de 2018
como Ninguno de los complots llegó a
nada los fiscales rebajaron algunos de
los cargos iniciales los sospechosos se
enfrentan ahora a asociación criminal
para la preparación de actos terroristas
castigada con diez años de